(upbeat music)
- Hey guys, it's Katie.
And you may not know this about
me, but I love deviled eggs.
I think my aunt Marilyn
makes the best in the world.
But today, I am testing out four celebrity
deviled eggs recipes and I'm
gonna have some taste testers
along the way and we're gonna find out
which recipe is the most excellent.
The celebrities that
we'll be facing off today
are Kourtney Kardashian, Joanna Gaines,
Ina Garten, and Oprah.
Let's see if I can keep up
with Kourtney Kardashian's
recipe, which is up first.
The first step for this is just
bringing water up to a boil,
which we already have here.
And then we're just gonna add in.
We're gonna add in a dozen eggs carefully.
There we go.
I did not crack it.
Maybe I should have done
these one at a time.
This is not a great method
to boiling eggs so far.
So we're gonna let
these sit for 10 minutes
then we're gonna drain
them and let them cool
for about five minutes.
So next we're gonna take our
eggs and cut them in half.
And then we will remove the yolk
and add that to a food processor.
I'm team, not Scott, but I'm team Travis,
but I'm not team like the PDA
like making out in front of her mom.
Would you make out in front of your mom?
Maybe, maybe you would.
The next thing is some Himalayan
salt, and we've got pepper.
She adds some yellow mustard in,
and then next, she has you
add some vegan mayonnaise.
Now this is obviously not a vegan dish
but maybe she's had
vegan mayonnaise before
and just likes it better
than regular mayo.
What I am most excited
for Kourtney's recipe
is she adds in a whole avocado
and then the zest of one whole lemon.
And then we are going to
squeeze about two tablespoons.
Beautiful.
Nope, nope. Great.
(food processor grinding)
Okay, she's looking pretty good.
So next thing we're gonna do
is I'm gonna put this into a piping bag
and then we're gonna
pipe it into our eggs.
Whoop. Oh, cute.
Oh my gosh! That looks
beautiful, Kourtney.
So I will give it a little chill time
and then we'll have our taste testers
and we'll see what they think.
Okay, let's do it.
- The color is a little
off putting definitely
- These ones are not the color
that I would normally think of
when I think of deviled eggs
- The color is odd to me.
It definitely is very
like avocado forward.
It's a little boring.
- Oh, wow.
- Yeah, I don't really like this, sorry.
- Our next recipe is from Joanna Gaines.
We'll take slice of bacon, dip
your bacon in the brown sugar
and then flip it over.
These guys are gonna go in the oven
at 375 for about 14 to 16 minutes.
We will be right back.
So Joanna boils her eggs
differently from Kourtney.
She adds them into the
pan before the water
which is something I would do.
Then she adds some vinegar
and this is supposed to make it easier
to peel the shell off the egg.
So we're gonna bring this up to a boil
then we're gonna turn off the heat
and let it stand for about 10 minutes.
All right, our eggs have been
sitting for about 10 minutes.
Let's take them and put
them in their water bath
which is going to also
help shock their shell
and make it easier to peel.
We've let the eggs sit for a
minute and they've cooled down.
So let's see how easy or not
they are to peel. Success.
I'm gonna keep peeling all these shells
and we will be back to make the filling.
So the next step and Joanna's recipe
is like all the other
recipes we'll see today.
We're gonna cut our egg, and
then again, remove the yolk.
So we're gonna add in some mustard powder,
some fresh dill, some chives,
dill relish, some mayonnaise
1/4 teaspoon of salt.
I feel like this is gonna
have a big punch of flavor.
What I am gonna say though
is we're not gonna get that
nice, super smooth look
that we got with Kourtney's
unless I am spending
like days mashing this.
Joanna says you can take a
spoon and put the spoon full in,
or you can take a Ziploc bag
fill it up and then cut a little corner
kinda making your own piping bag.
We're gonna add some paprika.
Now we have our bacon that
we dipped in the sugar
and then we've baked.
And I'm just gonna sprinkle
a little bit of that on top.
You can add a little dill,
and then she says you can add some chives.
We're done, these are gorgeous.
I'm gonna cover this with some plastic
and we're gonna let it
chill for at least one hour.
And then we're gonna see how they taste.
Let's do it.
- Deviled eggs are like a
loaded big potato, but for eggs.
And that is what this vibe is.
- Ooh, okay. These look
like winners to me already.
- It looks like there's
bacon on them, which is cool.
- I really appreciate the dill in it.
Give me all the dill, but I
don't love the sweet bacon.
- I'm very into these.
There's a lot of herbs, maybe
like a little pickled action.
I'm unsure.
Hmm. These are amazing.
- These are good, these are nice.
Maybe I'm not a big fan of deviled eggs.
- Next up we have Ina Garten.
She's only doing eight eggs,
they're extra large eggs.
so they're bigger but less of them.
So we're gonna bring this up to a boil
then turn it off and cover
it for about 15 minutes.
So our eggs are ready, I've
drained them of the hot water
and now I'm gonna be
adding cold water on top.
I think this is kind of
similar to an ice bath.
The cold water, I think will help shock.
These guys have been sitting.
So let's see how easy they are to peel.
Woo. All right, hey, this
method is great and works well.
So Ina wants you to use a stand mixer,
which is kinda like over the top,
but let's see how it goes.
We're gonna add in some sour cream,
a little bit of mayonnaise,
fresh lemon juice, some pepper,
salt, she's serious about her salt.
Then we've got cream cheese.
So she's definitely doing kind
of a play on bagel and lox.
She's got cream cheese
and she's got salmon.
And then we're gonna add in some chives.
Oh, that's so beautiful.
All the colors.
And then she wants you to
add a paddle attachment.
Okay, I think that's pretty good.
Okay, so she says to mix
this until it's fluffy.
So I get why she wanted
to do the standing mixer
so you can kinda get air in it
and it won't be this
like dense, dense thing
you're adding to your egg.
Well, let's see how it is.
Ina has you do the spoon method,
which I've been afraid of
this whole time, but we're gonna do it.
We're gonna spoon our
mixture into our eggs.
Maybe it won't be that hard.
I don't know why I'm afraid of it.
Okay, okay. Why did I have so
little confidence in myself?
We're gonna let these chill in the fridge
for about 30 minutes and
then we're gonna garnish.
Ina wanted you to put these in the fridge
because she wanted the
flavors to meld together
for a little while.
The flavors have been melding,
now it's time to garnish.
She has you add some salmon
roe on top, which is fancy.
Ooh! Oh my goodness.
Okay. So our salmon is on.
It's beautiful, it's glowing.
And now we're gonna
add some chives on top.
I'm loving this orange and green color.
Just getting so excited about eggs
But now, let's get our
taste testers in here
and see what they think.
- These are very extra.
- Ooh, these are fancy girls.
- These are so cute.
- That's delicious.
- Honestly, all I can taste is the roe.
It's pretty fishy.
- When that salmon roe kind
of explodes in your mouth,
it just gives you like this rush of salt.
I think it's really good though,
it just reminds me of bagels.
- Our final recipe of
the day is from Oprah.
She doesn't say how to
hard boil your eggs.
She's just like hard boiled eggs.
So I'm not gonna show you what I did
but I just basically hard boiled eggs.
Her recipe, I'm very excited about
'cause there's lots of
dashes as the measurements.
So I feel like it's just
like do what you like,
do what you love, feel it
out, which is very Oprah.
It's like you be you.
She likes sweet pickle.
I'm not a sweet pickle
person. I like sour pickles.
But we're gonna see.
We've got some mayo, fresh
squeezed lemon, a dash of it.
That feels a little bit more than a dash.
Then she has you do a
dash of horseradish sauce.
(laughing)
How do you do a dash? That's a lot.
And then she's gonna have you
do a dash of Worcestershire.
I hope I'm doing this right, Oprah. Sorry.
And then she says one to
two dashes of Tabasco.
I like a little spice, so
happy this is going in.
This is the only spicy one.
Like horseradish and Tabasco
is gonna clear up your sinuses.
Okay, so one, two, three, it
was about three. (chuckles)
And then she says a little bit of salt
and then a little bit of pepper.
This next part in her recipe
was a little confusing.
She said parsley two tablespoons.
She said that we garnish with it,
but she also said it goes
inside, it's very confusing.
So I'm just gonna put
half of the parsley in it,
and then garnish with the rest.
I like that her recipe was also written,
like it was almost a spell.
It was like a dash of
this, a dash of that.
Our mixture is complete.
Oprah also, spoon method.
I have conquered my fear
of this after Ina Garten.
I'm ready.
There you go. Gorgeous.
And then she tops with a
little paprika at the end,
and then we're just gonna
top with some parsley.
Oh my God, she's gorgeous.
Let's get the taste
testers in one last time,
and then we're gonna find
out who won this battle.
- Parsley has come to the party.
- This looks like a party.
- It's not trying to be fancy,
it's not trying to be
like really gorgeous,
it's just like, I'm a deviled egg.
This is what I expect from a deviled egg.
I think there's Worcestershire.
- It's a fun flavor.
- Okay, I don't want the
parsley, I love the pickles.
(suspenseful music)
- My favorite deviled egg was
the one with the roe on top.
Ina Garten put the roe on top.
- [Katie] Yes.
- Well that's in line
with what I said, right?
I said either it was like
a pretentious celebrity
or well trained chef.
We love Ina and all of her beach vibes.
That makes sense, delicious.
- My favorite I think was
definitely the bacon one.
- [Katie] Joanna Gaines.
- Oh, interesting. Very interesting.
Okay, I give her a lot of credit.
That was an exciting and
a very different take.
- My favorite deviled eggs
was definitely the last one
- [Katie] That was Oprah's.
- That makes sense.
That's what I wanted,
and she gave it to me.
- I've taken the top three deviled eggs
and I'm gonna try them very quickly
and be the deciding vote.
So here we go.
Now I'm gonna try Ina's.
Oh, okay, I like the smoke salmon.
Thought I wasn't gonna
like it, maybe I do.
Oprah, wow, the horseradish,
like that is singing through this.
Oprah wins it hands down.
It's just like what you
want from a deviled egg.
Good job, Oprah.
I feel like all of these would be great
if you were for hosting any event
but like they fit for different occasions
but I really feel like
this one would be a hit.
It's so good, it packs so much flavor.
It's got that acidity,
the mustard, so good.
Nice job, Oprah.
Okay, well let us know in the comments
if there's any other celebrity recipes
you want us to test out, and
we'll see you guys next time.
Bye.
- [Announcer] Oh, yes.